from the hill Elon Musk says he sold 10
000 of burnt hair perfume
10 000 of what bottles ten thousand
bottles there you go Elon has sold 10
000 bottles of burnt hair perfume
through his business the boring company
earning more than one million dollars in
sales from the product you're in the
wrong line of work
that's just it the billionaire announced
the news in a series of tweets he called
his burnt hair perfume doesn't get more
lit than this the world that's amazing
burnt hair
boring company well I thought it was
singed on the bottom there in subtext he
already made a million dollars he made a
million dollars it's a hundred dollars
yep Let the Flames Begin why I don't you
know what man I got mad respect for it
that's what it's all about
congratulations Elon Musk on your burnt
hair perfume singed it's amazing man can
sell anything he changed his Twitter bio
to a perfume salesman I believe oh wow
really yep
well dude gets it yeah I I you know I
wonder why it is and I talk about this
why people who are wealthy don't do more
weird stuff
what do they do with their money I was
talking earlier about some big famous
musicians and how they make millions of
dollars playing shows and I'm like but
you never hear anything from them it's
like they play the show and then they
disappear where does all that money go
does it just sit somewhere are these
people sitting there thinking like well
I'm gonna be 70 and then when I die I'll
have one with the most points is that is
that how it works I'm like do something
I just genuinely don't get it what I
just think about I was we were talking
about uh Trevor Noah leaving The Daily
Show and I think his salaries reported
as like 16 million dollars but you never
see anything from them right what is he
doing with all that money 16 million
bucks a year so he's on the show for
what a decade his net worth is 160
million at minimum if he didn't invest
it so let's say or if he spent some
maybe it goes down to 150 if he spent a
million bucks a year that's an insane
amount of money you can buy like an army
of giraffes and have them March through
New York you could you could do like I
don't get it I interviewed a quite a
famous British singer recently who had
like mad money was living in Los Angeles
and he was he was saying about um he
ended up getting a house that was like a
castle and there were just so many
people working for him that he would
like go downstairs in the morning and
there were like 30 cars outside and he'd
be like I don't I don't these none of
these cars are mine you know I don't
even know in the kitchen there'd be like
20 people they're like staff and he was
like yeah yeah this is not my family and
he got to a point where he was like you
know what I've got to sell this I gotta
change this life I'm always wondering as
well what are these rich people I guess
they must do a lot of stuff in secret
but where do they go when they go on
like a holiday right um there were loads
of I don't know if it's the same in the
States but in in Europe if you take like
EasyJet or Ryan a right you just go like
a two-hour flight to France there aren't
like
um more more expensive versions there's
just those ones and never on them I
guess they're getting private jets well
so so look let's say you're making 16
million bucks a year so what does that
come out to like 1.2 something 1.2
million per month per month a private
jet if you're flying right now it's
really expensive because of uh covet and
stuff but uh it used to be but now with
code and everything I think the cost of
a round trip from the DC area to Florida
as an example
I think the cost of that's probably
between ten and twenty thousand dollars
if you're making 1.2 million per month
doing a show you're flying private but
that's not putting a dent in your money
no you probably don't even think twice
about it but not only that they don't do
that they do this thing called netjets
where you buy a percentage of a fleet
and then you you it's like a timeshare a
jet share basically exactly and so then
when you need to fly you just call and
say this airport this place this time
round trip and then you pay for the fuel
basically but you own part of the plane
so you can always resell it so it's not
even that expensive it's probably like
two times as much as flying commercial
when you have the money to invest so my
thing is just like Elon Musk we know
what he's doing he's making burnt hair
perfume hey more power to him he's
making flamethrowers and digging holes
that's great everybody knows that deep
down men just desire to dig holes and
there you go Elon he's he's living the
dream man he's the the peak of all male
uh uh you know every male goal it's
funny that he made a perfume with his
drilling company boring company's a
company that makes underground drills to
drill tunnels and that's the one selling
it he also just wrote he also just wrote
a couple hours hours ago please buy my
perfume so I could buy Twitter
that could be one reason why he just is
like thinking of random products but on
a conspiratorial uh mindset it could be
the activation to the neuro link which
could be already inside of us because of
the Nanobots that were invested into the
individuals don't smell it so anything
is possible here too that is going to be
activated with the starlink satellites
that of course will make you into uh a
bot lidar that will serve the elites
kingsman the film that's what yeah right
exactly they had the thing in their neck
or whatever don't smell it it's in the
jet stream you can't it's going to find
its way to farmers in the midwest just
Elon Musk being like once I release all
of the burnt hair perfume into the jet
stream it'll blanket the planet and
everyone will be under my newer link
control it's a secret bio but he didn't
call it his musk he hasn't used the term
Elon Elon if you're listening elon's
must everybody wants it I mean this is
this is there clamoring for elon's musk
they would buy your urine man sell them
something delicious dude come on they
really would no but but uh I want to ask
you guys seriously like
someone knows what the rich people are
doing with their money or are they just
just I don't I don't I really don't get
it well I think a lot of people put in
mutual funds and let BlackRock take over
a couple things like black rock is that
it true a lot of it it's like oh I make
16 million bucks a year so I'll just put
all of my money into a big machine and
forget about it find like a a
run-of-the-mill money manager who's like
very you know stodgy and like does the
norm which is put this percent into
mutual funds put this percent in the
stock portfolio these stock portfolios
then the really rich people put it in an
offshore bank accounts that we don't
hear about again but but for what reason
I just don't get it for what reasons to
give to their kids right this is exactly
what this personal interview said
recently he said you know it came from
poverty himself and it it's another
status game isn't it it's another you
know how much you have and he said no
matter how much I've earned I always
want more I always want another million
another you're always looking at it so
and he said for future generations and
generations thereafter like constantly
but I you know it's true but
don't these people do things I don't
know maybe but like I don't think they
do anything I think you know people
really need to understand if you're
someone like if Trevor Noah's salary
really is that much
he can have anything he wants if he's
not buying yachts and helicopters and
all that stuff and he can buy those
things but like you want to go to a
restaurant he can have the entire menu
ten times over from one day's work he
can buy the restaurant with with with
one month's work you know or after a
couple months he owns a restaurant in
Times Square Millions Times Square
they're probably like 50 million dollars
somewhere but oh no a couple years of
work and you can own all of these
buildings all over the place well it's
like a psychological rat race it's like
I need more the other guy has something
bigger Jeff Bezos has something more and
then Zuckerberg has something more and
it's and it's uh it's a you know a
foregoing competition until you're like
okay I got too much money I got all the
power in the world what else could I do
to get some kind of feeling and emotion
let's go to that private island with
that Jeffrey Epstein guy that sounds
pretty interesting there and then that's
the nation that's essentially where they
all go it's like oh I'm Bill Gates I got
all the money in the world it's like
what can I do to get some kind of
feeling or kind of experience here I
already won the video game yeah let me
see what kind of evil ruthless crazy
stuff okay get away with well this is
actually true most people don't know
this but after you make your first
million they contact you the cabal and
they say here's the way the game works
once you reach 100 million you're
invited to Epstein's Island and then of
course all the rich people are like oh
yeah that sounds great I'm kidding I get
concerned with giving money to Future
Generations I don't I I'm not like at
the point where I'm like no seize the
wealth no more just like take them make
the money go to zero that seems so
extreme but the idea that you can hoard
massive amounts of money which is not
what its purpose is it's circulatory
it's supposed to be
you know that's the point of currency is
it's producing a current but this is
this is why people who are very wealthy
don't really have relatively that much
cash
you don't want to just got assets that
they that they transfer over upon death
and I don't know I think it's causing a
lot of greed and a lot of like
aimlessness because it's just the
numbers of what's important and that's
not what money is really intended for
it's supposed to represent goods and
services there's there's a certain point
where when you're making a certain
amount of money you can't you can't
become less wealthy so if you're a
middle class individual let's say let's
say you're making 75k 80k a year in the
United States you get a paycheck you get
to buy stuff you save some of it but
you're saving for something specific
like a vacation or for a rainy day fund
your money comes in you spend it on food
your money comes in you repair your
house your money comes in or you buy a
house your money comes in you prepare
your car
once you start making a certain amount
of money and I think the number is
somewhere around like I think it's after
80 000 a year you start having money sit
around then you start buying things all
of a sudden you buy yourself
um
you know you'll you'll buy a tablet that
tablet retains its value so at a certain
point you're no longer consuming you're
actually acquiring things of value for
people who are very wealthy
again just use the example of Trevor
notes we've been talking about him he
gets a million dollars in one month and
says I think I'll buy this building here
it costs 500 000.
he doesn't lose the 500 000 ever in fact
he makes more money from that so it's
it's a it's like it's like a curve at a
certain point you make so much you just
you're rich forever but but the it's
interesting you said 80 000 um because I
think that's also the point that
scientists say that your happiness just
levels up but that's why because it's
it's when it's when your basic
necessities are covered exactly in New
York it's like 160 to 200 000 for a
middle class meeting because of how
expensive everything is exactly that's
what it's but it's all averages is that
adjusted to inflation now because that's
probably a lot more no no 80
000 right now no no no no no nationally
nationally it's probably like 90 to 100
but uh this means if you're on average
you could be living in the middle of
Idaho yeah and it's gonna it's gonna be
less actually I think the middle of
Idaho is actually expensive it is but if
you're like let's say 100 miles west of
Chicago things are getting relatively
cheap nobody really wants to live out
there you're not far enough away but
you're not close enough and then the
property gets a bit cheaper but for for
for people who are in the upper echelon
this is why I I always question like
what are they doing are they just buying
houses and then having them but for what
purpose do you have more houses for what
purpose do you like buy a house or rent
it out so you can make more money that
you're not going to do anything with you
know I'm like someone's got to throw a
pie someone's gotta like just hire a
hundred clowns and have them run around
waving flags saying something like f
Biden they don't they want to give it to
their kids or just keep repeating the
Bill Gates pieing uh Saga that happened
and just have people running around with
Bill Gates masks and then other people
pieing them I'm just having that on me
that's what I would do hold on hold on
you came up with a really great game
show
so half the people are dressed up like
Bill Gates and the other half are given
pies and it's a you know the goal is
your x amount of Bill Gates uh
contestants have to be pied and the
other half have to like the Bill Gates
people not not get by and then you see
who wins at the end right what if it's
vaccinated instead of pied so 50 people
are running around and then oh yeah so
we get 100 people 50 have big novelty
oversized you know spritzers that are
shaped like syringes and their goal is
to chase after the people and they can't
run around they're gonna get heart
attacks but that's a separate
that I wanted to make here but but also
you know talking to a lot of people in
the service industry there is kind of
this conversation that usually some of
the most richest people in the world are
some of the most stingiest tippers out
there so there is something to say about
you know people's ego people's kind of
desperation people who have it all but
but mentally or are kind of bringing
themselves down to a point of view where
they you know are you know viewed as
high status but but they're mentally
their mentality is very low yeah I'm
gonna gonna I'm gonna buy some of this
burnt hair I always told myself I would
tip huge if I if I was rich I'm gonna
become super rich so that I'll just tip
huge and I realize like dude I'm rich
enough I'm just tipping huge from here
on out I just give massive tips like 100
tips or like 80 tips just load these
servers up man other people need the
money too you need to circulate that
stuff yeah well you can't just give
money away because when you give money
to people people don't respect it people
don't care about it you can't just give
out free fish all the time no it's not
free they worked for it they served me
they they got down the hands and knees
doing a job they hated to make sure that
I got good food fast they deserve it and
uh I think a big part of why there's not
a lot of not enough pushback against
BlackRock State Street Vanguard is that
people have their money invested in
these mutual funds and they're just
planning just trying to ride it out so
that their kids get it and that's that's
like gross mishandling of currency in my
opinion America is huge on tipping and
like when you come from any other
country in the world it's like oh my God
how much do I have to give so much 20
minimum but but wouldn't it be better if
if just the restaurant and I don't know
enough about so you tell me why if there
restaurants just paid their staff better
well yeah I mean you make more money you
know yeah you do make more money on tips
but it's weird because a lot of
restaurateurs will just say you get you
get this much money every hour and it's
like 10 cents but you have to make all
your money in tips essentially it makes
it make sure that there's good service
too so I prefer to tip then then just
have something not anymore it used to be
that they were like they want to make
sure they did well so they got a good
tip but now especially in cities they're
like you better tip me or I'll take a
picture of you and post it on Instagram
sometimes rarely but but you know in the
service industry now you get a mixed
batch definitely service has down uh has
been downgraded especially with people
being so entitled generally speaking but
but overall I've gotten some good cert
you know people who really do care about
providing a good service to people who
really do make sure that they do the
right thing and and make you happy and
and I I want to pay for that I rather
you know have that thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there